follow
your dream and n don't be afraid
to fail you will
fail sometimes john had a lot of success
there had to be some failures oh god
yeah
and you you learn success by failure so
you
overcome failure derek jeter the great
baseball player say
to be a good baseball player you have to
understand failure
i'll give the best example i'll use a
baseball analogy
if you're a baseball player and if every
ten
times you come to bat you get two hits
two hits out of ten you're in the minor
leagues
if you get three hits out of ten you're
in the hall of fame
never give up every block down is a
block
up every misfortune is a fortune
get off the porch don't give up
if you've got a goal in mind and someone
can tell you not to take that goal and
you believe it
you don't have a goal stay on course
i could go into a locker room that's the
truth
and not know the sport
and not know if the person i'm
interviewing i say the coach or manager
had won or lost and still get through
five
questions four or five questions without
knowing that like
what surprised you tonight
can you use tonight the next time you
play
did you have a plan for this evening
did they do something you didn't expect
what's the long-range effect of tonight
i don't know the sport i don't know if
they want a loss but all questions
are curious and to me
too many interviewers are not cured
they're curious they're only interested
in themselves
and not interested in the subject or
what the subject has to say and another
thing they don't do
is listen and the key to interviewing
is listening if i i've never gone i've
never asked a question thinking about
the next question
never had a question prepared i've got a
blue card that has bullet points
about the subject and what's been
happening but i've never had a question
written out ever
because if i start listing questions
then i'm going to look at the what's an
action i'm not listening to answer
this happened to me once
i i was touring for a book one of my
books and i was on a show called
uh good morning dallas it had a man
and a woman host now you can picture
what they look like i don't even have to
tell you
you know what they look like you're
right okay
now the woman is interviewing me she's
got the blonde hair the frizzle is
holding
and she's got six or seven questions
written out i can see them written
i'm sitting and she's sitting
and every time she throws to me to ask
if she were asked the question
i'm answering i could see that she's
like looking at the monitor
checking her eyelashes looking down and
she's not listening
i know she's not listening and the crew
knows she's not listening because
they've been watching her for years
so her third question is tell me mr
kingston i look intellectual
what makes a good talk show host
so i start dancing i see she's off
she ain't looking at all so i said well
i can't speak for others
but in my case what helps a lot
was being employed by the cia because
what the cia does is
they give me clues every night that i
send out signals
to spies around the world and they in
turn
get great guests from me and her next
question was
what's the effect on married life
so i it rings bad in my ear when i hear
because i think it's an art form and i
don't take much credit for it
because i had it when i was a kid i
was born with the gift of curiosity
i'm not a big believer in god or
anything i don't know where it came from
if there is a god i thank him
or her but wherever it came from
to have that it's a gift i remember when
i was a kid
at ball games the end of a game most
kids wanted autographs
i never would care about an autograph i
would run down the street
with a pee-wee reese later i got to know
but now i'm
10 11 years old i'm running down the
street pee wee in the third inning why
did they bumped
why did your butt why'd you do this why
it was always why
why and why still fascinates me
to this day why do people
do what they do what makes them tick
stay with what you want to do
if you like doing wreckage do wreckage
no i'm not kidding if your style is do
be yourself and don't give up if i can
talk you out of getting into this
business
you don't belong in the business because
the truth about this business is
there isn't anyone in it if you're a
disc jockey tonight in biloxi
mississippi
or your larry king live you're both
loving today
that disc jockey going into that studio
about to play country music
or larry king going into his studio to
interview uh
charles rangel loves it they're doing
what they love they may not like
the program director they may not like
the current
broadcast studio but they love what they
do when that light goes on
so if i can talk you out of being
excited by that light
find another business because everybody
in it wants to be in it there isn't
anyone in this business
who doesn't want to be in it frank is
not in it as much as he used to i
guarantee
he misses it i guarantee you there are
days when a big news story breaks that
he wants to be there
he wants to do that story if you if you
don't have that
don't try because the competition is
fierce it's a very
popular way to make a living because it
beats work
it does it beats work i mean they pay
you for something that you enjoy
they pay me to go to i never went to
college
that's how this scholarship started but
i go to college every night
i get paid to go to college i can
remember
being a boy getting on a bus school bus
and saying to the driver why do you want
to drive a bus
that would fascinate me and so later in
life i would ask
pilots are all flights the same
what what what kick do you get out of
taking an airplane up i remember asking
a pilot once he said he'd never been
asked this
i said when you're going down the runway
right
and you're going 80 90 100 do you know
it's going to take off
you know it's going to take off and he
said
i know it's going to take off i don't
know if it's going to elevate
i don't know if it's going to elevate
i'm going to take off but if there's
something goes wrong in the engine i
could crash right there
but i will lift i have to lift the law
of aeronautics
will have me lift but if i lose an
engine the lift is going to go down
that's kind of like life isn't it yeah
so i try to ask those questions
that i think humans ask
as new yorkers said street questions why
do you want to do this
so whether it's nelson mandela or jackie
robinson or frank sinatra
they all put their pants leg on one leg
at a time
they're all human presidents are humans
singers are human
victims are human uh people who are
having tragedy in their life or having
exaltation in their life
they're all still people and they're all
still what do you feel
what what's it like to be president
what's it like
what surprised you about the office
what don't you like about it
if you're a former president what do you
miss about it
why why do you do what you do
how much of it is caring for other
people how do you really feel you're
representing an
entire country how's it how do you
handle criticism
see all these things boggle me
there's a motto i don't know who wrote
this first but i adopt this is my motto
and if you think about these students
think about this i
never learned anything when i was
talking
i think people lose sight of that fact
and so if you watch a lot of television
hosts delaying radios
they're talking more than the guests the
best interviews and the best answers
come from follow-up questions often of
course and when you get the i
interview you know they get like here's
an example
all right let's say frank sesno has
written a book
uh my career is a dean okay
no let's say what are you laughing
you're putting yourself down
frank says those might come as a shock
to the dean
or or you may learn by four o'clock that
you ain't
okay here's all right frank says no my
life is a dean and this is today's
broadcast host the ego host okay the
self-involved host
okay good evening tonight's guest is
frank sesno author of my life is a dean
i never was a dean frank
i i always wanted to be a dean i thought
about being a dean but you've written my
life as a dean
i've skimmed through it a little and i'd
have to say that when i go through
schools i often wonder
what a dean does i'm sure that you
answer that uh
what does dean mean now you try to
answer
uh being a dean means you're beginning
with the word being
a being is a sense of self
now what
what we learn from that is nothing
but we learned that the host is
self-involved it's just now but the
other thing you don't do larry is you
don't
another part of self-involvement in the
host getting you don't call people names
you don't say oh you're stupid or you're
a jerk oh no we're never
you want to know the dumbest way to
begin an interview is that way
or let's say no
again let's say you're interviewing
osama bin laden right you'd be the
number one get in the world that would
be a big interview okay all right
worst first question worst first
question
why did you plan the bombing of that
building
what would your first that's the worst
first year your first question be to
osama bin laden
why did you leave the riches
of saudi arabia from one of the richest
families
to live in the hills now that
takes he knows i'm interested in him i
haven't
made no objective i've i'm objective i
sincerely believe
he's going to have to want to talk about
why he would leave a life of privilege
for this life that he's chosen now
gradually we get to the other things
it's on your list i've got to take him
into me
right the worst way is to be
argumentative not maybe thrilling
television he may scream back
but you don't learn anything and what we
want to do with a guest is learn about
the guests
i also love comedy when i do
speaking i only speak and tell funny
stories i do not speak seriously
uh i work a lot of conventions tony
robbins that's where i first saw work
i worked on tony robbins i worked on
other
self-help things that i always go on and
say what am i doing here you know i
don't have any books to sell i don't
have nothing to sell
right and i just tell stories and tony's
wild to work with
tony used to introduce me by
starting on the stage and taking l
give me an l come here and then he'd run
through the audience go up to the
balcony
run across the balcony you know spelling
out my name
until he got down until finally larry
king and i
said that uh i think we ought to put a
rocket up his rear
and shoot tony up to the clouds he will
not be happy
until we sort of blast him off to
jupiter sure
but a lot of fun with tony and uh so i
like doing this and
fact that's one of my favorite things to
go out on a bare stage
there's nothing like the high you get
when you can make people laugh
when you can walk out cold nothing
behind you no script
no play no guests
just go out so i did a comedy tour two
years ago we worked boston and miami and
all over the south and uh it was just
great just going out on stage
we we knew where we were going whether
it was directed
but uh a lot of times would be ad-libbed
and i
i just loved it i loved going out there
a lot of my friends at comics
and i've always admired comics i love
interviewing comics
comics see the world differently they
see things funny
the new yorker magazine did a story on
me once and they called it
every man so i never assumed
that i was better than the audience or
smarter than the audience
i didn't go to college i never pretended
to be an intellectual
i left my ego at the door i learned a
long time ago you can't make someone
like you
be yourself the only secret
in our business is there's no secret
there's no secret there is no secret be
yourself you can't make them like you
you can't if the audience doesn't like
you now you ca you can do anything you
want you can't make a money
like you don't it's a magical thing why
they like it
so i always assumed i'll just be myself
therefore i leave my ego at the door
i don't ask questions that begin with
the word i
i'm insatiably curious i care about my
guest
i never think about the last guest i
don't think about tomorrow's guest
in other words if yesterday i've
interviewed the secretary of state
today i'm interviewing a ballet dancer
and tomorrow i'm interviewing
the president united states i am totally
into the ballet dancer
i don't let my thoughts go haywire
and i can't explain that i don't know
where that came from john in other words
i could have a bad day but it will not
affect me when that light goes on
when that light goes on bam
man it's like home to me so i'm home
and i'm honest and i care about what i
do
and i think that in retrospect that
transfix
when it started i didn't know i just
knew i wanted to be a broadcaster
what's your favorite joke that you love
to tell or that oh i've got
if you can only tell one joke
what's the one you would want it's some
of the most recent ones i've heard well
i'll give you two
yes uh there's a train that goes every
night
from new york to chicago it's an all
pullman train
all sleeper leaves new york at one in
the morning and gets to chicago at 10 in
the morning
guy checks into his compartment and
suddenly the door opens and a woman
checks in now normally
amtrak would not sell single woman
single man to spend the night together
but the
was the last seat on the train the woman
insisted she had to be in chicago
so they said okay she got into the lower
birth the man got into the upper berth
and the
train began his trek after a little
while the man leaned over and said i'm a
little chilled
could i borrow a blanket the woman
looked up and said you know
we're never going to see each other
again we're on this train
for one night going to chicago we've got
nine hours together
we just snuggle up a little why don't we
why don't we play man and wife you and
me man and wife the guy said sure
she says good get your own goddamn
blanket
that's again the other one was uh those
are funny yes
uh this uh in aragon
this uh company that chops down trees is
hiring
people to chop down trees a foreman is
interviewing people
and a one-armed [ __ ] shows up a [ __ ]
with one arm
applying for a job as a treat cutter and
the foreman says you got to be kidding
he said no i can chop down trees he says
okay here's an axe go out there and
there's a bunch of trees jumping down
the [ __ ] goes out carrying the axe
along the ground picks it up and
whack knocks down 20 trees in a minute
whack he comes back performance says you
are the greatest tree cutter i have
ever seen you're hired you're
unbelievable you're a one-armed [ __ ]
but you
where did you work last he says i worked
the sahara forest
he says you mean the desert he says well
now
i always want to be in radio since i'm 5
years old i don't know where that
came from but i just wanted it
i used to listen to the radio and they
would say things like
a tail well calculated to keep you in
suspense i would go into my bathroom
close the door and go a tail well
calculated i wanted to be
a radio announcer it's all i wanted to
be i had no interest in money
i just wanted to communicate on the air
when i was a teenager i'd visit
radio shows that had studio audiences
just to watch the announcers
stand in front of the microphone what
that was like and i desired it didn't go
to college my father died when i was
nine
we had i had a younger brother who was
six my mother couldn't go to work new
york city bought my first pair of
glasses you're wearing glasses somewhere
new york city bought my first pair of
glasses we were on they called it relief
and they paid our rent and i lived in a
little attic apartment and were very
poor
but i wanted to be on radio couldn't go
to college
worked at a bunch of odd jobs ran into a
guy one day who suggested i get down to
miami i went to miami i had 11 dollars
in my pocket
stayed with my uncle and knocked down
doors and finally a small radio station
i did test at the microphone said they
hire me and i start
the following monday from friday to
monday
i'm up all weekend picking out records
what i'm going to play i was a disc
jockey
now it's my big day on the air may 1st
1957 i broadcast in seven decades
this is my live stream the general
manager calls me into his office and
says
what name you're going to use and i go
my name is larry zeiger i said you can't
use zyger
today they would it's too ethnic
people know how to spell it you need
another name i'm going on the air in 10
minutes
he's got the paper open to the miami
herald for which i would later write a
daily column
and it was an ad for kings wholesale
liquors
and he said how about larry king oh my i
would later legally change it
so i said okay now i go in i sit down
it's nine o'clock the record starts
swinging down the lane
let's sell it i lower
the record turn on the mic nothing comes
out
i bring up the record i lo nothing comes
out i look at the clock it's like three
minutes after nine
and i tell myself i can't do it
i wanted to do this all my life but i
can't do it
i'm scared i can't do it the general
manager kicks open the door
and says you better communicate this is
a communications business
and he slammed the door i turned the mic
back on and i
swear to god to you john here's what i
said this is
it's almost 60 years ago good morning
my name is larry king that's the first
time i've said that because i've just
been given that name
and all my life i want to be on a radio
and this is my first day
and i'm scared and i'm nervous so i've
been sitting here fading this record
fading it up and fading it down
so i better and then the guy just opened
the door and said i better communicate
so i better communicate and i've never
been nervous again
ever because i arthur godfrey told me
you learned the secret that day
you were yourself you were truthful to
the audience now think about this i
didn't think about it then
any goof i made if i cued a record wrong
screwed up a commercial
it's his first day put the audience in
my shoes
take them into my grasp and i've lived
my life that way so my first day on
television
i it was radio with pictures i've still
regarded that's way this what we're
doing now
is radio with pictures so all my life
no matter what i've done whether it's
radio television
internet i'm doing the same thing i did
60 years ago
i'm asking questions i'm transmitted
differently
whether it's satellite phone line
internet
i'm doing the same thing i'm doing what
you're doing right now
it's what i did 60 years ago love it if
you want to see the tribute video we
made to kobe
bryant check it out right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there there's a choice
we have to make as people as individuals
if you want to be great at something
you have to make inherent sacrifices
that come along with that family time
hanging out with your friends